[Musica]
Ovviamente vi state aspettando un'ora di
Finanza Però come vedete il mio
armocromista non ha cambiato invece che
grigio Siamo invece sulla speranza sulla
speranza Perché il colloquio di oggi che
faremo insieme riguarda il capitale
umano e quindi nella speranza che
funzionano le slide Eccole qua parleremo
quindi di cos'è il capitale umano e
della difficoltà nella quale mi trovo
occupandomi di finanza nel parlare di
una cosa che in questo momento viene
portata da tutte le imprese dai governi
come una vera emergenza sociale quella
di dov'è questo capitale umano Cos'è
questo capitale umano e Lo affronteremo
in una dimensione che la dimensione
odierna quella di una società 5.0 e
capiremo subito che cos'è e quindi
partiamo Un po' come vedete dall'estate
qua da una rigenerazione che deriva dal
fatto che capitale ha una sua
definizione ben chiara che io sono
andata un po' a cercare per avere punto
di partenza per voi che mi fosse un po'
più vicino e quindi ho cercato una
definizione che è quella di capitale che
si trova ovviamente in Economia e come
vedete c'è un ricorrere un po' della
stessa parola la parola beni beni che ci
permettono di avere degli impieghi
produttivi beni che ci permettono un
ritorno investment Un ritorno sul nostro
investimento ma da un punto di vista
umano Questi beni quali sono
effettivamente bene questi beni sono
le Life Skills le competenze per la vita
l'organizzazione Mondiale della sanità
nel suo distretto per la salute mentale
già abbiamo detto tutti 30 anni fa
proprio parlò delle Life Skills come
quelle abilità cognitive che permettono
di affrontare la vita di prendere
decisioni di gestire la costruzione del
nostro benessere personale e nei
confronti degli altri Quindi andiamo non
può vedere queste competenze per la vita
e cerchiamo di immaginare come se
creassimo un vero e proprio portfolio di
queste competenze per la vita e come
vedete sono diverse e partono dalla
capacità di prendere decisioni quindi
sviluppare un pensiero autonomo nel
momento in cui vada ad affrontare una
certa situazione e poi la capacità di
risolvere i problemi che vediamo qua e
quindi vuol dire farsi parte proattiva
nel non fermarsi affrontare l'ostacolo
magari a girarlo ma andare oltre con
quello che è un pensiero autonomo che è
il pensiero creativo un pensiero
indipendente che non guarda allo
standard ma cerca di personalizzare la
risposta alla avversità così come il
senso critico fondamentale soprattutto
mi rivolgo a tutti coloro che sanno cosa
vuol dire
ludopatia digitale sanno quanto sia
importante
particolare delle dipendenze
comportamentali che a volte partono solo
con un like così ci agganciano in una
situazione che nello shopping compulsivo
nel Trading speculativo nel gioco
d'azzardo attraverso digitale ci può
catturare e portare fuori strada e poi
ovviamente la comunicazione comunicare
Chi siamo noi i nostri bisogni le nostre
debolezze i nostri punti di forza poter
essere letti dagli altri e leggere negli
altri Grazie anche alla capacità di
relazionarsi in relazioni che possono
essere estremamente positivi ma possono
anche essere negative allora la capacità
di distaccarsi da queste relazioni senza
atti violenti Senza arti cruenti ma
soprattutto con la nostra capacità di
conoscerci e nel conoscerci di portarci
nei confronti degli altri in una maniera
costruttiva da un punto di vista sociale
e poi ancora la gestione delle emozioni
è quello dello stress lo stress che può
essere di diverso tipo lavorativo
l'ansia lo stress finanziario arrivare a
fine mese le difficoltà che ci cadono
addosso e poi ce n'è un'altra perché un
po' come 10 comandamenti c'è sempre il
numero 10 in questo caso è l'empatia
l'empatia la capacità di mettersi
all'ascolto degli altri mettersi nei
panni degli altri senza giudicare ma
cercando di trovare un punto di
connessione che metta insieme tutte
queste competenze Voi direte avrete
fatto un po' cielo cielo cielo manca Ok
va bene o nasco così oppure mi succede
qualche disgrazia come dicono tutti e
dalla disgrazia io rinasco con le Life
Skills Ecco no ancora meglio quello che
voglio dirvi è che le live Skills sono
competenze Skills competenze vuol dire
che si possono insegnare si possono
imparare possono arricchire quel nostro
portafoglio di vita e come si insegnano
vi porto alcuni esempi il primo esempio
come vedete è quello della Danimarca in
Danimarca ci sono le classi di empatia
le classentied dai 6 ai 16 anni i
ragazzi costantemente lavorano
sull'ambito dell'epatia questo osserva
costruire i leader di domani serva a
combattere le situazioni del bullismo
serve a creare relazioni tra le persone
che poi si portano nel tempo Tanto è
vero che la Danimarca di fatto e ai
primi posti non solo come paese felice
ma soprattutto in termini di qualità del
lavoro Perché nascono leader lavoratori
lavoratrici che sanno lavorare
sull'empatia perché hanno fatto fin da
piccoli Vi do un altro esempio di
applicazione del Rescue se veniamo alla
fuoriuscita dall'Europa veniamo alla
Gran Bretagna Ecco che il Public
speaking e in particolare il teatro e
nei curricula delle scuole nei paesi
anglosassoni permette ai ragazzi alle
ragazze di mettersi in gioco di poter
portare le proprie emozioni le proprie
fragilità comunicarla agli altri e
quindi riesce attraverso imparare la
comunicazione obbligatoria a scuola
anche poi ad affrontare un colloquio di
lavoro anche poi ad affrontare momenti
nella vita Nella quale essere autentici
è sempre l'aspetto più importante e
quindi a questo punto Voi direte Ok due
begli esempi due aspetti fondamentali
mio viso di quelle competenze per la
vita che ci aiutano a giocare una
partita fondamentale che è la partita
della vita e che lavorano nell'ambito
scolastico per un cambiamento che deve
vedere quelli impoverimento che abbiamo
visto nelle nostre scuole nei curriculum
delle nostre scuole purtroppo non
aggiornati purtroppo non all'altezza
vedere un vero cambiamento partendo dai
più giovani e quindi veniamo all'Italia
Che cosa sta facendo L'Italia in questo
ritardo che vede la scuola un passo
indietro Avete visto tutte queste
discussioni perché studiare il Verga
perché non diciamo aggiornare anche i
programmi letteratura magari inserendo
anche nella lettura nell'arte qualche
donna qualche scrittrice visto che a
livello di toponomastica già ce ne sono
molto poche nelle nostre città o in
generale in Italia Ecco un primo passo
avanti l'abbiamo fatto quindi con la
legge
2782 del 2022 e dopo due anni di
sperimentazione fatta anche dal punto di
vista del terzo settore sia arrivati
finalmente a una legge per inserire
l'insegnamento proprio della
intelligenza emotiva nell'ambito delle
scuole un primo passo è vero un grave
ritardo però sicuramente un primo passo
avanti incoraggiante e quindi da una
parte abbiamo le competenze di vita e
dall'altra parte come detto fan parte
del Ted X le competenze digitali da una
parte lo Human touch dall'altra parte
l'intelligenza artificiale volevo con
Roy rompere questa dicotomia culturale
perché non c'è O l'uno o l'altra una
contro l'altra perché insieme questo
tipo di competenze veramente possono
fare la differenza nelle persone possono
arricchire quel nostro bagaglio quel
nostro portfolio di competenze e insieme
anche a quelle ovviamente di educazione
finanziaria su questo non voglio
tediarvi ma dirvi soltanto che
finalmente col ddl capitali a fianco
dell'educazione Civica Ci sarà
l'educazione finanziaria per un paese
che dal punto di vista dell'indicesi
europeo Metà della popolazione non ha
competenze digitali di base e che dal
punto di vista delle competenze ed
educazione finanziaria e praticamente
fanalino di coda sia negli adulti sia
negli adolescenti potete capire come
acquisire questa conoscenza acquisire
questo bagaglio di competenze diventa il
punto di svolta E perché diventa il
punto di svolta diventa il punto di
svolta indipendentemente dalla
generazione alla cui apparteniamo perché
in questo momento è cambiato il mondo
del lavoro e quindi pretendiamo vogliamo
che scuola imprese ragioni in una
maniera diversa e prenderei spunto
proprio dall'ambito 5.0 Sapete che la
rivoluzione 4.0 è nata in Germania
mentre la 5.0 qualcuno di voi sa dove è
nata
paese più vecchio del mondo non siamo
noi Noi siamo un secondo in Giappone
yuko harayama viene chiamata dal primo
ministro giapponese per cercare di
reinventare E riportare un dialogo nei
confronti di quell'innovazione digitale
che arrivava troppo veloce a cambiare le
vite delle persone in un paese che come
sapete è stretto da un punto di vista
anche dei limiti emozionali dei limiti
sociali che non è facile affrontare ed è
quindi che yuko harayama parla proprio
della società 5.0 parla della società
5.0 e quindi ci introduce verso un nuovo
paradigma culturale un paradigma
culturale che passa dalla 4.0 Quindi da
una rivoluzione industriale basata
sull'information Technology
sull'internet of Things Sul rapporto
uomo robot reinventando questo rapporto
e portandolo nei confronti di che cosa
delle stanze che ovviamente in questa
maniera siamo vendo in un mondo in cui
la l'ansia di risolvere le problematiche
ambientali di risolvere le problematiche
sociali che riguardano le persone che
ovviamente vanno più in là con gli anni
ma dobbiamo affrontare delle altre
situazioni perché se arriviamo a 120
anni non tutti ci arriviamo pienamente
in salute quindi tante sfide da
affrontare mettendo l'uomo al centro
costruire una società umanocentrica
resiliente sostenibile lo si può fare se
si usano le tecnologie non con un'ottica
di profitto ma con un'ottica sociale che
faccia Sì che quel famoso isg veda nella
S di sociale qualcosa di molto forte per
il cambiamento della nostra società
soprattutto per far sì che lavoratore
lavoratrici con quel bagaglio di
competenze veramente possano fare la
differenza e costruire una società 5.0
ora a questo punto
viene il momento in cui dobbiamo un po'
tirare le somme di questo incontro che
abbiamo fatto e dobbiamo cercare di
ragionare su un altro aspetto come
affrontiamo tutto questo che cos'è il
capitale umano un insieme del nostro
talento come abbiamo visto di competenze
che possiamo insegnare che possiamo
imparare che possiamo acquisire siamo
noi il capopale umano siamo noi quel
cambiamento culturale necessario
indipendentemente dalla nostra
generazione dalla nostra appartenenza
perché quella società che deve andare
oltre le questioni di genere oltre le
questioni di diversità Ma deve vedere al
centro esclusivamente la persona nella
sua essenza nella sua capacità di essere
il motore di questo cambiamento con
coraggio con empatia con la capacità di
essere veramente sociale e consapevole
perché la consapevolezza di sé e la vera
libertà e quindi vi lascio con questa
che è presa ovviamente da buone lo devo
fare è una frase presa dal Talmud Dai
perché a volte dalle massime dei Padri
ed è una frase dove vedete ritorniamo
anche a un libro molto famoso di Primo
Levi e dice se non se io non sono per me
Chi è per me e io sono solo per me
stesso Cosa sono e se non ora quando
questo vi dice esattamente come dicevano
Falcone Borsellino Se non ora quando
adesso il momento di agire adesso il
momento di prendersi la propria
responsabilità sociale prendersi in mano
quella capacità di acquisire quelle
competenze che ci possono far sentire
parte della società in una maniera
empatica entusiasta non prendendo dai
modelli virtuali dei social che sono
modelli fine a se stessi perché modelli
commerciali perché modelli che vendono
una perfezione che non c'è la vera
perfezione sta nell'aver la
consapevolezza di noi stessi nel poter
lavorare per noi stessi e per gli altri
per poter rigenerare le nostre
creatività con il nostro senso di
responsabilità sociale con quella
leggerezza del cuore che vuol dire Forza
coraggio sentire capire comprendere e
condividere relazionarsi nei confronti
degli altri Quindi concludo dicendo che
dal punto di vista del cambiamento
culturale Noi siamo il capitale umano
Noi siamo al cambiamento culturale e non
posso far altro che augurarvi di
riportarvi al centro di questa che non è
un'utopia ma è la realtà già di oggi già
di adesso Se non ora quando Ora noi
possiamo essere società 5.0 per
partecipare a un'impresa 5.0 che è
inclusiva e che lavora per il nostro
futuro insieme e quindi non posso far
altro che augurarvi piena consapevolezza
per voi per gli altri per il vostro
benessere e brindare con voi alla vita
le haim
Grazie